ideas that we have to follow, such as that
our people in our masks
is an existential relief, that is, I believe
that if the human being is
drowning in the trivial,
we are drowning in the everyday,
I would say, and vital because we are being,
we feel drowned in  In
everyday life, that is, the pod of the pod, it
creates a
base level of anxiety that seems unsustainable to me.
deaths of people who die from
war or natural disasters or
have decided to overcome the idea of ​​committing
suicide because they feel so
good an unsustainable
unsustainable
good but but don't allow the question to
be because it says like a gene is said to be
a being  human can live a week
without food 4 34 days in water but he does not
live even an hour without it without it because he
follows the cycle of the aspect that gives
meaning to his life you understand why
because the Huilense filter filter doubt if
you do not have a something something  that has something that
fulfills you then you become
miguel de unamuno the tragic meaning of
life is that about karabakh there is a
whole book saying that life
has no meaning because we are mortal
so there is the tragic meaning of
life so how do we compensate  in order
not to commit suicide we are mortals we know
that we are mortals what a
horrible imposition we can turn what
we have into some kind of
[ __ ] asian cool poetry of emotion as a
prisoner in life imprisonment also
if it were the
minsa they can't stand the beach in the winner
of the match in  menguante de sants
but but but as
in a title license
yes right now the only thing that
does
and give us permission as to why
you want to avoid selling a
fantastic film for snub for that same reason
because it's about your mind and no henry
was finding  themselves
d
music
of you
in the
country
for my life with
life and i
the
councilors between countries in species the
counter playing of
the
leader this wey
and now
bye
in giant
yeah
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
and
I
[Music]
d
i
uy
and it is
that
meets
about